americans are lining up for food
from california to the midwest to new
york
with the national thanksgiving holiday
approaching demand for food assistance
is increasing
along with new filings for unemployment
benefits the labor department
says they increased by 742 000 in the
last week
reversing recent gains
[Music]
you don't think the yourself
you don't think you're going to lose
your job
things happen new york has been hit
particularly hard
it's one of 15 states placing new
restrictions on businesses
an 80 percent increase in new covet
infections nationwide over the past two
weeks
is keeping tourism down broadway closed
and restaurants at limited capacity
experts warn
it is likely to be a difficult winter
new york state as a whole
was regaining payroll jobs at a slower
rate than any state other than hawaii
uh through september on a year-to-year
basis
so the recovery was already slow and not
quite steady
and these most recent developments have
knocked us for a loop
and any reversal of the
reopening is going to cause an even
greater decline
in new york subway and bus service could
see drastic cuts
along with the layoff of 9 000 transit
workers
ridership and fair income has fallen in
the pandemic exacerbating prior budget
shortfalls
the metropolitan transportation
authority is asking congress for 12
billion dollars we know that any
reduction in service will hurt the city
and the region including customers who
need us most
but without the certainty of substantial
federal dollars there is no recourse
and we must plan for the worst while
hoping for the best in the wake of a
crisis that has done more damage to our
finances
than even the great depression in the
thirties but republicans have been
reluctant to put aid to state and local
governments in any federal relief
package aid to states like new york
could come down to which party wins the
senate
and two contested seats in georgia up
for a runoff election
in january if no aid deal is reached
millions of americans are due to lose
their unemployment benefits by the end
of the year
kristen salumi al jazeera new york